ever wondered how that delicious sweet
corn on your dinner table came to be
it's not just Nature's magic but also a
result of smart efficient and
sustainable cultivation
technology today we delve into the
fascinating world of sweet corn
cultivation right from the humble seed
to the Golden Harvest our journey begins
with a single
kernel the
seed this seed isn't just any regular
corn seed it's specifically bread for
its sweetness it's a product of years of
research and selective breeding chosen
for its high sugar content and tender
kernels once the seed is ready it's time
for planting but it's not as simple as
just throwing seeds into the ground
sweet corn requires specific conditions
to grow the soil needs to be rich in
nutrients and have good drainage the
seeds are planted about 1 in deep and
about 8 to 12 in apart to allow each
plant enough space to grow after
planting comes the nurturing phase the
plants need regular watering but not too
much as corn has shallow roots and can
easily become water logged as the plants
grow they also need protection from
pests there are various methods for this
from natural predators to the use of
eco-friendly pesticides as the plants
mature they start to Bear ears the part
of the plant we commonly refer to as
corn each ear is covered in a Husk and
contains rows of kernels these kernels
start off as small white dots and
gradually swell and turn yellow as they
fill with sugars the key to sweet corn
sweetness is in the timing of the
Harvest the sugars in the kernel start
converting into starch as soon as the
corn is picked therefore the corn must
be harvested at just the right time
usually when the silk at the end of the
ear starts to turn brown but while the
husk is still green once harvested the
corn should be cooked and consumed as
soon as possible to enjoy its full
sweetness but if you can't eat it all at
once don't worry modern freezing
technology allows us to preserve the
sweetness of the Corn for later use so
that's how a Single Seed transforms into
the sweet corn that we all love it's a
process that combines traditional
farming methods with modern technology
resulting in a crop that is not only
delicious but also sustainable and
efficient the benefits of this
cultivation technology are numerous it
allows for higher yields better quality
crops and more sustainable farming
practices it's a testament to human
Ingenuity and how we can work with
nature to produce something truly
wonderful sweet corn cultivation is a
Marvel of modern agriculture each kernel
on your plate is a testament to the
power of technology and the endless
possibilities it holds for the future of
farming so the next time you bite into a
cob of sweet corn remember the journey
it took to get to your plate and
appreciate the Marvel that is sweet corn
cultivation